[Music]
all right so here we're gonna talk about
beyond static reports with our markdown
so hopefully everyone is is somewhat
familiar with with our markdown but it's
a file format that allows us to to
create HTML PDF reports Word documents
you can knit two presentations but but
there's a whole world kind of beyond
that of our markdown and it's it's a
really flexible format allow allows us
to do a lot of different things hmm so
we're just going to gonna walk through a
couple of those different uses today and
with that let's let's go ahead and jump
right in so hopefully everyone can see
the IDE that I have pulled up here this
is kind of a classic are markdown report
so I'm going to call it a static report
I'll go ahead and admit it so we can can
just know what we're talking about and
so just grinding through code so this is
gonna create a report for Facebook right
for FB pulls in the the price history of
Facebook it charts it there's this
really simple well we're calling a
forecast model down here in the bottom
and hopefully this looks really familiar
to everyone as something you can
accomplish with our markdown right this
is basically an HTML file we could we
could save this and send it to whoever
we're wants and they would receive it
and be able to read our work the reason
I think of this as being kind of the
most static I'm almost even hard-coded
you can almost think this is a
hard-coded our markdown file is that
everything is kind of explicitly defined
here right this is a report and I'm
saying it's for FB I'm passing in this
ticker symbol FB there's a few more
examples where it's just fbfbfb that's
really the guts of what's going on here
and that's great come but this is this
is not really a document that's easily
kind of changed or used for different
purposes right so we can imagine if
somebody said wow this this report looks
really great could you could you set it
up for Google or for Amazon for net for
Netflix right some other stock and and
we could definitely do that right we
could we could just do a ctrl F and look
for all the instances of FB and replace
it with something like Google and we
could say replace replace replace that
that would work right it's it's a
probably a bad idea for a few reasons
you know one of which would be that this
is a really simple report though we
would still almost inevitably make a
mistake at some point as you can see
right here I have googan I'm actually
pulling in data from Google so if I did
another find in replace on goo this
immediately would mess me up but even if
we were really meticulous about that you
know for one thing we've we've lost our
original report on Facebook and so we
could say well no problem we'll just
make a copy of this file we could call
the first one Facebook port our MD and
then excellent Google dot report not our
MD etcetera etcetera
that would also work but if we ever
wanted to make any changes to maybe this
this this forecast down here maybe we
want to make this maybe a little bit
more complicated or a better model
instead of just calling this simple one
we'd have to change it in every single
one of those files
so our markdown has a more flexible way
of doing this and that's this concept of
a parameterised report okay so so this
file is going to it's going to produce
basically the exact same report we were
just looking at for for Facebook I'm
just I'm going to knit it here just so
we can look at it and confirm that I'm
not lying so here's the exact same
report the difference is that up in the
yam while I created a parameter and I
named that parameter symbol because
these are ticker symbols and I gave it a
default
you have FB right so if we go back to
our original document you can see that
the animals look slightly different but
now if you search through this document
you won't see FB appearing anywhere else
you'll just see params dollar symbol and
here's params dollar symbol so now if I
want to create what we call a variant of
this report from myself as the the
creator of this report I don't have to
do a ctrl F and and replace FB with with
Google I could just do it right here
right then I could say agree okay I'm
just gonna pass in this ticker so
everywhere that originally there was FB
now there's this goog this is one way
you could do it you could just change
the default value that's perfectly valid
way and okay it works
you could also when you knit this
instead of just clicking on the net if
you click on this downward arrow you say
I want to knit it with parameters
because what we've created here is as a
parameter we've given it the name symbol
okay so maybe looks a little familiar
from from the shiny world and actually
we get this little interface and it's
gonna say okay well what what ticker do
you want you see I put in I can put in
Amazon I could go back to FB I could go
away from the tech world and say hey
well well Goldman but in any event to me
this this report has taken one step away
from its original static hard-coded
nature right because it's a lot more
flexible now for me to pop in different
stock tickers and indeed any parameter
that you wanted to pass in to save this
model you could parameterize so this is
kind of the first step right towards
towards to me making this a more dynamic
document again I think two valuable
things one less likely to make a mistake
- now I can I can change this underlying
code without having to worry about doing
it for all these - all these different
variants in this report so I'm going to
just kind of kind of head-on here
because that that very simple case
probably doesn't doesn't really jump out
as being all that useful so let's look
at this slightly more complicated case
so here I've almost intentionally
created a lot of parameters that they
don't even kind of gonna fit on one
screen so this is a script that's going
to take gonna take three stocks these
default values to Google Amazon and
Facebook
there's the parameters or stock one
stock two stock three each of them gets
a weight we're gonna create a portfolio
stocks so they they need a way to eat in
that portfolio we're gonna assign an
interest rate and we're gonna have a
starting date and one of the things so
we're still up here in the ammo and one
of the things that this is going to show
I hope is that the parameters don't just
have to be text they can be numeric
alright so the weights are all going to
be numerix this this risk-free interest
rate is going to be a slider input this
is going to be a date let's just knit
this and it's kind of default format
hopefully it all it'll help show how
we're moving towards the things being a
little bit more dynamic right and some
of it depends on the point of view from
which we're defining dynamic versus
static this point to me this document
has become much more dynamic from our
perspective as the creators of this
document from the end user or the end
consumers perspective this is still
static they're still getting an HTML or
a PDF report from us right from our
perspective it's more dynamic we can
change it faster
so here's with that that document knits
- it's gonna take our three stock
tickers combine them with the waiting's
that we gave them it's going to tell us
how the dollar would have grown it
calculates the Sharpe ratio which
measures the risk/reward trade-off of
this portfolio on page two here just
shows us the monthly percentage returns
of these individually if that was
important to us
right but there's a lot of there's a lot
of parameters here right so hopefully
this demonstrates a little bit more how
if we wanted to create a variant of this
if this had been our original hard-coded
example where we were going to go
through and do a control F on every
single parameter that we needed to
change that would get a little bit
complicated here and we would become I
think more likely to make an error right
so we probably don't want to be doing a
control F here and trying to change
things throughout the code right so and
this also I think shows of why it's it's
going to get difficult to just change
things directly in the am alright here
was easy to change the different tickers
there's only one so we can pretty easily
change the symbols now when we have to
have more and more we want to actually
really make use of this knit with
parameters button so let's see what that
looks like with these different formats
so one we can we can change the title
how about energy stocks BP Chevron is
another one exxon so these are the these
are all text inputs as we had before but
now we have these numeric inputs right
so we can change the weighting this when
we do a 40 30 30 sure how about the
risk-free rate we're assuming we could
take it up that's gonna make our Sharpe
ratio go down the start date oh sure
2013 so hopefully this is showing that
that this is at least my opinion greatly
decreasing the likelihood we're gonna
make an error and miss one of these
parameter somewhere and it's making it a
lot easier to kind of kind of create
variance in this report and I'm gonna
walk through the code a little bit once
we're done here but I just wanted to
show what the end result is gonna look
like
so the we're not just walking through
code sort of blind alright so here's a
here's a new report write growth of a
dollar invested in
I mean energy has not been a great place
to be for the last four years it
actually has a negative Sharpe ratio but
you can see them you know by changing
all those parameters we change the title
now it's called energy stocks right
here's the individual returns so it's
pretty fast to iterate through different
variants of reports for us as the are
coders again what what the end-user
would be receiving here would still be
quite static so we'll just quickly look
at how these parameters get get passed
down into the code that that portion of
it is actually you know it's pretty that
part's pretty intuitive you create your
parameters up here and then you pass
them into the code the same way you
would anything else right so so this is
just a function it's not being affected
at all by any of the parameters right so
kind of this the same as the way we load
it up an unpromising report start with
your start with your packages and create
whatever sort of function that you want
and then here's where we start passing
in parameters right we have a portfolio
name that was one times our first
parameter stock one that's our second
parameter started here with with a date
graham dollar date so we're just passing
these parameters the same way as we
would if we were quote-unquote
hard-coding them but this just makes it
a lot easier to to create variants of
this so again this is all sort of from
the our coders perspective this has
become a more dynamic document and a lot
easier to to change and we if we did
want to update this model in some way
you know maybe we maybe we want to
change this function to daily stock
returns or weekly stock returns you know
or indeed maybe if we wanted to have
that be parameterised you know we can
make this we could add a parameter here
make this attacks and call it something
like my params dollar period or
something like that right and then we
could create a parameter up here and
then all of a sudden we'd be able to
toggle between monthly weekly daily two
different types
of period returns all right so that's
that's kind of another at least to me
another nice thing about parameterizing
these is that is that it's a little bit
of a mindset shift because now all of a
sudden this to me anyway this feels like
a more dynamic document and I can start
to think well what can I promote our
eyes what would be interesting to
parameterize well here I think this
period might be interesting to
parameterize we're getting along returns
with a parameter in our parameter as
that maybe we just want if we don't want
log returns for whatever reason if we
want continuous returns the the opposite
side of that coin of course is starting
to think about well what what should I
not be parameterizing right maybe we
want to enforce a risk-free rate so
maybe we might want to obliterate this
and just quote unquote hard-code the
risk-free rate and say this is one thing
we're not going to toggle it's an
assumption
it's an unchanging assumption let's
change everything else and see how the
different reports come out so a lot of
flexibility again this is for us as the
as the creators of the reports right all
right so to me the ability to secrete
these multiple parameters takes us
another step towards towards being more
dynamic right so this is the original
hard-coded right then we just had had
one parameter and then we have a lot of
parameters and because maybe eight total
parameters right we could keep going you
could put ten there's really really no
limit to the number of parameters we can
put in here and then just you know we
knit with parameters it's going to give
us a nice interface for changing the mom
all right so now you know hopefully I've
convinced you that this parameter is a
ssin is a valuable thing for us as the
creators of these reports but let's take
the next step to to to shiny and this is
where things are just they're always
going to be dynamic in the sense that
even the end user is going to receive a
dynamic document and again a lot of the
important stuff is happening up here in
the amyl which to me is kind of the good
news even though as our coders maybe the
Emel isn't the most intuitive place for
us to be you know it's it's nice that we
can just make these changes up here and
not have to touch our code a lot there
are some changes in the code but this is
really where a lot of the important
changes in a format are happening I'm
just again gonna gonna quickly knit this
and then we're gonna we're actually
gonna go way back to the beginning of
shiny apps but I just want to show where
we're headed with this shiny world so
this is you know the things you could
say the most sort of dynamic iteration
of this in the sense that here we would
be delivering this app to an end
consumer we'd be saying you can choose
your own stocks and your own weights
right and you can see in you know real
time how they change so this is kind of
inherently dynamic it's it's never gonna
take a static state and just stay there
so both for us as the the creators and
for the end consumers this is always
going to be a dynamic document and it
looks very similar to those reports
right I'm gonna I'm gonna come back to
to the code here I just wanted to
quickly show where we're headed so that
we can kind of get a picture of it so
this is this is the code that was used
to create this it's very similar to the
code that was used to create those
reports that the main difference is up
here in the yamo we have this runtime
shiny instead of having all these
parameters right so we include this
runtime shiny line our machine our local
our desktop when we're running this or
whatever server this is sitting on dosed
okay this is this is a shiny app and
when our machine sees these parameters
it knows okay this is a this is a
parameter edge report or if we had this
sitting on a connect server somewhere
right but just in case there's maybe
some people out there who are more
familiar with the traditional way to
create a shiny app I'm gonna take a
brief departure here and just
just start at the beginning with shiny
and then we'll come back to this and
we'll go through the code so we came to
a five minute departure here okay so we
here's kind of a classic shiny app it's
sitting in an app dot our file you know
this is the the hello world example
right one of the hello world examples
where it can change the number of bends
and see how it affects the histogram
right so we have our inputs reactive
sitting between these and then and then
our output switches in this histogram
alright so here it is in the appetite of
our file and then here is just a Flex
dashboard skeleton with runtime shiny so
if you want to just get started and and
began kind of playing around with with
Flex dashboard and the ability to create
shiny apps there what you can do is you
can take your entire app dot our file
and you can copy it alright so I just
need control a control see there this is
just if you want to get started playing
around and you can can you can copy the
entire app dot our file into that first
coat chunk right library shiny UI fluid
page and you can run this document
within the RMD and it will will
basically reproduce that shiny app in a
Flex dashboard format so I just copied
the app that are over 2 flex dashboard
and here's pretty much that exact same
map right the reason I think is useful
just to do this in the beginning if
you're just getting started and you're
more used to app dot R than using Flex
dashboard and our markdown for creating
shiny apps you can kind of deconstruct
the shiny app and put it into its
component pieces and see what what is
needed and what is not needed and I our
markdown base shiny app versus the more
classic app dot our shiny app so the the
first thing that's not needed is just
library shiny and get rid of that
because we've already called runtime
shiny so we don't need that there's
really no concept of UI and server and
in the Flex dashboard in our markdown so
we can we can get rid of that you can
see we we had to do a lot of work here
to tell the UI this is a sidebar layout
it's a sidebar panel a fluid page title
panel that's not really how it's handled
in in our markdown file we just tell it
up here this is a sidebar right and then
we we drop in a line of dashes and
that's how Flex dashboard and our
markdown knows there's a there's an
element coming here and we thought it
that it's a sidebar now we can actually
we can get rid of this fluid page we can
get rid of sidebar layout in sidebar
panel because I just told it it's a
sidebar but to me this is gonna be a
just a much simpler app right now that's
gone numb okay so this is our sidebar
I've called it inputs you can call it
whatever you want you call it sidebar
you could you really just give it the
name any name you want this is really
what's what's telling our markdown that
this is a sidebar for inputs and I think
we just want that slider there for
inputs right we don't really want our
outputs sitting in the in the sidebar
we're gonna make that its own code chunk
yeah we'll come down here we'll create a
new coat chunk for our outputs okay now
we have all these kind of extraneous
parentheses we can get rid of those main
panel we don't need that main panel and
the reason why is that we've indicated
here that this is a sidebar we want to
let let our markdown know that we're
done with the sidebar by putting in
another another line of these dashes so
now our markdown knows okay we're done
with this sidebar let's go to the main
panel we don't need this anywhere
alright we said there's no server or UI
logic way to deal with function input
output I want to deal with that okay
getting pretty close I promise shiny app
UI well we got rid of UI in server
take this out this is an orphan now take
that okay what's nicer so we have our
our inputs we have our outputs know you
I know server logic really need it here
you can get rid of some of this white
space does really matter let's see what
this looks like when we run it always an
adventure to do these live never quite
know what's gonna happen when we
deconstruct and reconstruct okay so this
looks like a pretty close approximation
of what we had before in our app dot our
file it's probably a matter of personal
preference or just aesthetics which one
we prefer there's not really a big
substantive difference between what you
can do an app dot are and what you can
do in in our markdown shiny file I
personally like this format better I
think this is simpler I think that you
could probably show this to someone who
wasn't all that familiar with what we're
doing here today and say this is this is
the sidebar it has a slider input and
these are where the outputs go the
output is going to be at that histogram
so to me this is just a little bit more
intuitive and a simpler way to layout
your shiny apps there's nothing wrong of
course with using the classic method of
F that are but today we're just talking
about our markdown so so this is the way
we're going with today it is actually
you could make this even more
parsimonious you could take out this you
don't need plant output just pot output
dollar this plot you can take that out
we can knit this it would be would be
fine just prove I'm not lying hopefully
this is going to be fine okay so it
looks the exact same
I like to keep it in there though and
again this really is just a matter of
preference
I just find kind of mentally having this
at the top it makes it easy to just
glance up and see that this is this is
where I'm putting it output it's not
necessary to have it in there so just
just to kind of complete this and show
what I think is kind of the power of
using our markdown for creating shiny
APS's let's say we wanted to add another
plot that was responsive to another
slider or really any input it's it's
really fast and easy to do that or
markdown so this is how you add a second
slider just copy/paste it I'm gonna call
it pins to distinguish it from input
pins one and I think we want another
histogram it kind of be responsive to
that one and one this to be responsive
to pins two we'll call this upper two
and this output two so let's just knit
this up all right so now we have a
histogram on the left is responsive to
our first slider histogram on the right
is responsive to our second slider we
could put these on different pages we
could reorient them we could have a
sidebar that just has the first slider
and then on the second page slider that
has that just has the second one the
point hopefully that that I'm
demonstrating but it is really easy to
add new elements and drop things into an
our markdown flex dashboard when you're
building your shiny apps for me I just
find it a little bit easier than
dropping elements into the kind of
classic app dot our file where I would
be dealing with you know these three
calls if I wanted to put in a new input
and then I need to deal with my server
logic I just think it's a lot easier to
kind of drop things and there's a whole
website devoted to flex dashboard called
our markdown there's two
slash flex dashboard and then there's a
whole section on SHINee so I'm not going
to go through this but this is all out
here the different different layouts
over here right some different examples
of shiny or here so anyway I highly
encourage if you'll want to get into
building SHINee with with our markdown
this website is a good place okay so
that was a little bit of a have a detour
just to to make sure we're all on the
same page in terms of how to port over
SHINee apps that were constructed using
the app that our format over to a Flex
dashboard so now let's look let's go
back to a tool the Flex dashboard or the
shiny up we want to look at it's
basically going to be built on the exact
same components as our example right so
here's our example the key line here is
runtime shiny um same here runtime shiny
we're gonna we're gonna load up our
packages here in the setup chunk and
we're going to define our functions
right so very similar to to any other
shiny app you can define whatever
functions you want up here in the set up
and then they're accessible to you a
question though that we get a lot about
SHINee in general is well what functions
can I drop into a shiny app the answer
is any of them any function you can
create here can be called in this app so
then just to kind of refresh everyone
what this app looked like because I know
we took a detour over there to look at
the hello world example well we have
this this sidebar and our hello world
example of this was just a slider input
but here we have the stocks I throw
weights starting date the mystery rate
this is sitting in our sidebar and the
actual chart is sitting over here in our
in our row so that's happening right
here at our sidebar okay the reason
is double line instead of single line is
that you'll notice when we toggle back
to it that this sidebar only appears on
the first page of this app doesn't
appear in the second page okay so here's
how we constructed the sidebar for this
shiny app and I actually did use the the
fluid row format here and there's a
reason for that which is that this shiny
app is trying to put a lot of elements
into this sidebar alright so we have 8
inputs if we didn't go with that fluid
road they would just be stacked so we
would have 8 different boxes 1 2 3 and
it would start to you I think kind of
hard to see it on one screen so the
reason that I went with that fluid row
is just to be able to put them next to
each other it's also a little bit more
intuitive to have the weights there so
the the point is that you're not going
to lose the ability to put to put you
know nuanced layouts into your shiny app
by going with our markdown the same
things that were available to us and an
app that are available to us within the
sidebar I still think it's a little bit
easier just to house them within just
this sidebar call so we we have our
reactive our inputs and stock 1 weight 1
the basically we're mirroring the the
parameters that we had here and I'm
parameter eyes report right stock - wait
- and I'll stop toggling in a second
because I'm sure everyone kind of gets
it stocked - wait - the code is is very
similar it has a different layout
because in this case we're you want the
user to have the chance to actually do
it themselves and then we come down to
where we're actually gonna going to be
passing those reactive inputs to the
function that we returned that we
defined up in the setup code junk so we
pass in a year and one
two three and we calculate portfolio
growth we're gonna calculate the Sharpe
ratio which is what's sitting in those
value boxes
these are knowledge calculations we
haven't actually done any charting and
graphing yet and this is this is an
interesting place to look and a shiny
app so here's three lines that are
layout oriented they're not substantive
we're telling that with this double
lines we're telling this shiny app this
is page one and we're saying this is
this is the first row of page one and
this is the name of it so remember that
portfolio growth row group one time
maybe we want to call it something like
portfolio performance let's see how that
affected the end result of the app so
now this is
one portfolio performance when we talk
about page two you're gonna notice the
sidebar is gonna go away I know it
actually I'm sorry reason the sidebar
doesn't go away is that we defined it as
a universal sidebar if you come back up
here to the top see these double lines
are telling this app this sidebar is
universal normally this is how you
define a page but since we called
sidebar first flex dashboard and our
markdown now okay we're calling a
universal sidebar though we can keep
keep toggling no matter what page we go
to so that's kind of a substance of
choice do we want each page to give the
user the ability to change inputs and
outputs some sometimes yes sometimes
nose and yells we won't want that so
back to page one which was portfolio
performance we said this is going to be
our first row we're gonna call it growth
of $1 and then very similar to what we
did in our hello world example we have
in this case it's a dy graph output and
our hello world example we just called
it plot output because it's kind of
dozen besar we're using a simple plot of
the histogram here we're using dy graph
so we're going to tell you call GUI
graphs I'll put in dollar graph rendered
I do my graph and we're gonna we're
gonna pass in our reactive to it here so
very similar to actually our hello world
example the only difference here is we
have a couple of functions more
complicated functions sitting in between
our inputs and our outputs right that's
really the only difference is that
instead of just passing in these tickers
straight to our output we're running
them through through these functions
here other than that this is really just
the exact same as just hello world
example so so hopefully I'm convincing
you that you can take your app thought
our shiny apps in and and kind of parse
them into an R markdown file and have
them do the same thing and what I think
is a nice format then let's let's take
one more look at this
we're not just looking at code you might
have noticed that in addition to the
chart that's showing the growth of a
dollar which is here which is here we
also have these two value boxes it's
down here and those are gonna be
responsible to any any change that we
make there to activating Sharpe ratio
all right so so let's look at look at
the Flex dashboard code and how we
actually put this into the file well we
had to tell our markdown there's a new
row coming because the first row had
that chart that was showing the growth
of a dollar so we had to tell it okay
there's a new row and first piece of
that row is gonna be called the Sharpe
ratio of our portfolio and it's a value
box Ken and it's gonna again depend on
that reactive Sharpe ratio that we
defined up above which again is really
just the inputs passed through some
functions right so we said okay new row
first value box is here and then with
these three hashes we said there's a
second there's a second element coming
in that second element is also going to
be write a value box okay so that's how
we told that's how we told our markdown
that there's a new row it's going to be
these value boxes and we don't want them
to be very high because we're just
showing a couple of numbers so we you
said data height 200 right which is
really just an aesthetic that we're
setting and it's a relative aesthetic in
the sense that it's not an absolute to
200 it's it's going to say well if this
is 600 down below was 200 it's going to
set these heights relatively which is
why down here we said okay let's make
this data height 350 this is just some
background on the Sharpe ratio it's it's
really just here to kind of show that
you can also include static content not
everything has to be reactive when
you're when you're building a shiny app
in our markdown you can still put in
just like you always can in our markdown
you can still put in your your text
right so if you want to have some some
tech
in here and you want to write something
up about your shiny app you can still
drop that in to your to your shiny
application right so I just said this is
going to be a new row and I said let's
give it a title background but then this
is not in a coat chunk right this is
just text the same as we would always be
doing with our with our our markdown
files and and then we said okay let's
drop in a second page where we can just
show the monthly returns this is this I
think of is almost a way of just telling
people you know we're doing all this
these calculations we're passing all
this data through these functions we're
calculating the growth of a dollar or
showing the Sharpe ratio but if you want
to look at the we could think of as
almost like raw data just the monthly
returns for each of the stocks that you
selected here it is right so this is
probably just a personal preference of
mine I almost always like to have a page
to where there's some sort of way to
look at raw data the data that I haven't
really passed through a function here
we're changing it into monthly returns
it's not just prices but it's a place
for someone if they are so inclined to
to check out that the raw data and
you're lying it so this is page to
individual stocks we could call it on
maybe do a monthly returns I'll just
change it just so we can and see how
that's going to change the final output
we have a page called individual monthly
returns with monthly misspelled but but
that's okay right and again so this is
going to be responsive or to our sidebar
of course because it's pulling in the
percentage returns of each ticker so if
we start changing these to MPP and IBM
we're gonna get different monthly
returns because these are different
ticker symbols right okay all right so
I'm gonna I'm going to pause here for
just a second and I'm gonna I'm going to
take a look to see if we have we had any
questions come through and one is can
you enforce constraints in their
relationships yes you can you could you
could define them in that way but you
could also yeah you can't enforce the
constraints you you would really just
need to to code to put it in the code
but I I can send you an example on that
if you if you send over an email how
they do it how can you use flex
dashboard with SHINee server and the
answer is the exact same way as you load
your app dot our file is you would load
up this RMD file in the exact same way
and when the server quote-unquote sees
this file and the server notices this
runtime shiny it's going to know this is
a shiny app so it's going to be the same
way as you were loading up your app
thought our files but I would really
just encourage you if you want to try it
out just you know grab that grab that
hello world example put it into a test a
test our MD and then put it on your
shyness or currency but but but trust me
it'll it'll see this runtime shiny and
it'll know it's a shiny AB and the next
question is is a similar question can
you run through the deployment options
for shiny our MD it is the same as a
shiny app
so if you have shiny amp yo account it's
the exact same you'll publish it by
pushing a button if you have a shiny
server setup you'll you'll move the are
markdown file the same way as you would
your app dot our file if you have a
connect server it's the same process
you'll you'll push your button and
you'll zip it up to connect so there's
not going to really be a difference in
publishing the I guess the only
difference is if you're used to using a
UI and a server individual file that's
not really going to be part of an arm
markdown based shiny app it's almost
it's going to be gonna be one file but
yeah those are those are very good
questions because obviously we need to
to deploy these in some way and those
are the only questions I see ok great
thank you for those questions and I'll
just if anyone has others please put
them in the chat there was a couple of
other things that I thought might be
interesting to cover so I'll just kind
of plow ahead here and I'm gonna I'm
gonna toggle over to to a different set
of our markdown reports slash apps
I'm similar setup in the sense that we
start with a none parameterize document
we move on to a parameterised document
and then we move on to to a shiny app
right so this is this is kind of my
workflow for almost anything I'm
creating start with something uncommon
Erised the simplest case move on to
parameterize and then the shiny one
thing that having that workflow enables
is that is that if you want to kind of
stuff your functions into a helpers file
right so so what we've talking to over
here is a slightly different use case
this use case is gonna kind of build a
portfolio of stocks going to calculate
their volatility so we're leaving the
world of stock returns to calculate
their volatility let me calculate the
contributions of each asset to the
portfolio's volatility right
but each of these three documents under
a motorized parameterised and the shiny
app if you look at their setups I'll
toggle down to you right now their
setups are all exactly the same we start
out by loading up these packages right
this is all three files and then second
thing we do in each of them is we load
up this dot our file and that dot our
file has a set of functions that that I
defined earlier and one to calculate
component returns which is here's the
first one right the second function in
here calculates contribution volatility
of each asset that's chosen and then the
last one calculates the portfolio
volatility alright it doesn't matter
what the substance is the point is that
one of the things that I think makes
building shiny apps in our markdown
quite efficient is that if you're
building a report using our markdown and
you're building a parameterize report
using on lockdown and then you're
building a shiny app using our markdown
they can all use the same this same
helpers function right so to me that
that's nice
because I don't have to worry about
changing all three of these right if I
want to I want to mess around or test
out functions over here I can just do it
in this in this one file and then all
three of these are pulling them in right
kind of same with formatting there's a
lot of efficiencies to be gained if you
know if you spend a lot of time
formatting a report the way you want it
so this is our under eyes report if you
spend time kind of formatting this and
getting it to look and feel the way you
want and then you decide I want to turn
this into a shiny app it's not a lot of
work to take this structure and and put
it over here in fact it's going to be
really really similar you know once you
have the look and feel the way you want
it and your unpromising static report
you can take
to parameterize land a less static
reporter then you can take it to shiny
and all the trial and error that went
into making this report look good almost
all of that learning is going to
translate into your shiny app it's going
to be a little bit different because the
look and feel will vary because in the
shiny app of course you're giving the
user those that sidebar inputs where
they can actually put stuff now change
stuff so you need to kind of think about
that but other than that these formats
are going to mirror each other so I kind
of find that there's a lot of
efficiencies especially for someone like
myself I don't really want to spend a
lot of time thinking about formatting I
want to spend as little time there as
possible
I wanna spend as much time as I can here
and helpers dot are working on these
functions and I want flex dashboard and
our markdown to him really handle that
that formatting for me so that's just
kind of another little what I think of
as an efficiency gain it's not really
substantive I mean you know you can you
could very easily take any of this work
and poured it over to a classic act on
our you know shiny app and if you're
very familiar with formatting those
shiny apps then that that'll be easy for
you for me I'm just much more
comfortable formatting our markdown
documents and the fact that I don't have
to leave the world of our markdown to
build a shiny app just saves a lot of
trouble having to reformat things so I'm
just gonna go ahead and knit this file
because there's one thing that that I
want to show you all that's it's not
specific to an arm markdown shiny app
but hopefully you'll find it helpful so
then
this happens a little bit more
analytically I'd say well at least time
consuming than the other one right it's
it's building a portfolio calculating
standard deviations and then when the
contributions over timing that's having
to do that for three different stocks so
I'll push I'll push go here you'll see
it's gonna take a second to run and I'm
kind of doing that on purpose all right
so all right so you can see that this
app didn't start running until I pushed
and go which is which is different from
from this app from the Sharpe ratio app
this this was calculating the new Sharpe
ratio every time we changed a parameter
which really isn't that efficient it
isn't that big of a deal if your app was
gonna run extremely quickly meaning it
isn't doing a lot of heavy computations
but for this volatility app I don't
really want that because every single
time anything here gets changed if I
didn't have this go button it would
start trying to recalculate recalculate
recalculate and that would eventually
drive our end users insane so apologies
if this is kind of old hat for people
but but the way that we handled that was
here with this action button go right
so clearly the what that's doing is it's
waiting for someone to push go before
anything happens and then the the link
between this button and the rest of our
app is right here so instead of creating
a straight-up reactive which is what we
were doing here in our original app our
Sharpe ratio app right these are just
reactives right they're not waiting for
anything that they're just waiting for
inputs reactive reactive reactive here
we're using an event reactive and this
event reactive is saying wait for input
dollar go and don't do anything until
you get that input dollar go so I just
it's not specific at all to our markdown
shiny apps this is the same
you would you would have in a normal app
that are but I I like to just kind of
point it out whatever whatever I'm going
through shiny-ass because it can save
your end-users a lot of grief and
frustration from having things run every
single time they change an input I mean
it's it's really it's not hard to get
this set up you just add an action
button this doesn't have to say go we
can say like submit or something
whatever you do whatever you kind of
want to tell people to do it's just
waiting for input go to get to get fired
off right so that that's gonna it's not
only going to change the performance of
your app and since we're doing two
calculations we need it twice here so
I'm calling two of reactives input
dollar go this probably isn't the
greatest construction in the world but
what it's saying is so now render hi
chart knows when you're high chart is
waiting to get this value portfolio
rolling standard deviation right so with
waiting for that input dollar go to get
fired off because then that's when these
values we're going to get passed down to
it so that's just going to make you know
life a little bit easier on your end
users and just just for completeness if
you don't want to see what this looks
like in the parameterize setting it
looks like this right so similar to what
we were just showing our end users right
different different options here baking
stocks I don't know those are pirating
banking stocks but you can see Wells
sure
we'll see what happened before the
financial crisis I thought did it let's
see how long this is gonna take to MIT
this this app takes a little bit longer
the the functions and helpers are
they're not you're dependent on a
built-in function but they're not
completely built-in so they're doing
some slicing and dicing but okay here so
here's that that parameterised report
right it was pretty easy to create a
variant of this and I wouldn't have had
I wouldn't have wanted to create a
variant if somebody had asked me to so
this is showing the volatility of a
banking portfolio it really spiked here
for the financial crisis
Jevon driven almost completely by Wells
Fargo had to get bailed out by that by
the federal government and then the
Wells of the Purple Line here slowly
starts to take down as they announced
they were gonna pay back their their
bailout kind of plumbing it even had a
negative volatility they're paying back
their their tarp money but in any event
you know this relies on that exact same
structure the only difference here is
that you know one it's calling on this
helpers file
so again I just find that takes away a
lot of a lot of having to update things
in different places if you can have your
files to pin them the same thing there
might be a good reason not to do that
and then something someone else is
working on but for this one it worked
out well and then you know key you know
just purely thinking about our end user
experience which is not a natural thing
at least I can only speak for myself as
someone who users are typically we're
just thinking about delivering our
results we never probably have really
had to think about what's it gonna be
like when someone interacts with this
you know shiny web application what's
their experience gonna be like but this
section but will make their experience a
lot better so hopefully we don't you
know especially if you're doing work
that you can do a lot of a number
crunching it'll save them some grief
and also let them know like okay I push
to go something's happening now so
things aren't just kind of happening on
the screen without their control hey
Jonathan we're coming up just to the top
of the hour and it looks like you have
one more question you see watch it okay
so do you ever see our plush Ani
functioning in the browser without a
server requirement like say J s um not
really so you need a so I I haven't seen
that that's not to say that that it's
that it's impossible the the main reason
that you kind of need a what we call a
shiny server sitting underneath here is
that it's going to be running your R
code right so so that's that's a big
thing with that shining server is is
doing when you're serving this up it's
running the R code and then bringing
back the calculations to the end user
that's not to say that this is
impossible
I never say things are impossible
because there's probably someone out
there who can figure out a way to do it
but but not something that we see
[Music]